monsieur le premier ministre merci
d'être là manuel suis très heureux de
vous voir parce qu'on s'était rencontré
à l'elysée vous avez été extrêmement
sympathique on avait rigolé ensemble et
lors d'une décoration je suis très
heureux de vous voir et franchement non
c'est un honneur pour nous d'avoir
marqué ce qu'on dit toujours pas si le
premier ministre est toujours j'espère
bien ça veut dire que maintenant vous
avez acheté du pain ou l'histoire de ce
premier jour
simplement appelé manuel aussi c'est
vrai comme ça dans vous allez bien
d'autres événements forts moi je vous
vois à la télé vous êtes en forme vous
n'êtes plus beau que jamais non mais
c'est vrai c'est sympa merci j'aurais dû
venir ici avant tout pour voir que c'est
complet merci d'abord de cette
invitation puis moi aussi je suis
heureux d'être là c'est très commentée
un ancien premier ministre dans votre
émission ça devienne de plus en plus à
ne pas rêver il ya même des anciens
animateurs
puis j'ai assisté un suspense
insoutenable
je n'étais pas bien je n'ai pas bien là
je me disais que va-t-il se passer
quand on est premier ministre c'est un
crois parce que je me dis du jour au
lendemain quand on quitte sa fonction
comment ça se passe parce que c'est vrai
que tu vas voir les centaines de coups
de fil des centaines de sollicitations
comment ça se passe le lendemain parce
que ça nous est non c'était incroyable
de passer de tout est-ce qu'on passe du
tout de suite de tous à rien nos pas la
dent dans mon cas parce que je suis
parti pour être candidate s'était
appelée gentiment
à la primaire de la gauche et ça s'est
terminé comme comme vous le savez est
donc donc du coup je suis rentré dans
une campagne donc j'ai pas eu le temps
de vivre ce moment où le portable le
sommes plus mais c'est vrai que quelques
jours après la la presse m'a vu en train
de normalement de prendre le train avec
avec ma valise et cette image sur le
quai d'une gare en allant en campagne
pour la primaire avec la valise donner
le sentiment quand les faits j'avais
j'avais perdu toute la parade puis je
sais ce qu'on perd tous les privilèges
c'est à dire que vous aviez certainement
chauffeur vous aviez de la sécurité est
ce que du jour au lendemain non parce
que dans mon cas d'espèce et pour les
anciens premiers ministres on reste
c'est le cas encore aujourd'hui d'accord
protéger parce qu il y avoue le savait
la sarre et c'est important d'en parler
mais c'est sûr mais mais mais ça reste
cette réalité mais moi je vous savez
c'est d'être franc j'ai vécu je trouve
extraordinaire dans ma vie d'avoir été
maire député ministre et polémiste
jamais quand j'étais gamin son nom est
levé avec l'idée tu seras un jour là
haut et donc quand on perd ça oui on
perd le pouvoir l'action que j'ai
toujours aimé mais moi j'ai connu un
choc personnel d'adhérents 2017-2018
j'ai senti une forme de mort politique
quelque chose qui se brisaient en moi je
te raconter dans un bouquin dans mes
mémoires pas aussi nommé dans un livre
que j'ai publié à quelques mois et donc
j'ai senti le besoin de partir parce que
sans doute les coûts que j'avais reçues
gouverner c'est difficile c'est ça reste
un bon souvenir quand même mais ça reste
surtout un souvenir leurs
responsabilités incroyable servir son
pays mais c'est vrai que nous avons
connu une période particulièrement
difficile marqué chez avant tout par les
attentats terroristes mais est donc ça
ça ça vous change la vie ce qui est
important ce qui est moins important
dans l'action gouvernementale est dense
et celui dans tous les membres du
gouvernent dans la politique et équité
au gouvernement à ce moment là bien sûr
de récupérer tous étaient très très
marqué le marquage françois hollande est
et bernard cazeneuve notamment et puis
et puis on pense on pense en permanence
aux aux victimes où nous sommes en plein
dans l'est dans une recette des
attentats du 13 novembre donc on vit
forcément avec cela sans doute ça m'a
marqué trop marqué parce que ça a changé
ma personnalité
mon visage on envisage les choses
différemment on est sans doute plus rude
mais je vous jure et rajeuni c'est ce
que me dit ma femme tous les jours voilà
ben je suis papa de femmes et je vous le
dis quand même ça pourrait mai
je pense qu'on va vous savez
quand on pense à ça on se dit oui ça a
été formidable de servir son son pays
même dans des circonstances difficiles
mais à partir du moment où on n'a plus
les responsabilités la vie est belle je
vous manque ça me manque quand même oui
ça manque bien sûr banide certaine
manière pas tous les jours mais ça
manque oui vous savez les politiques qui
vous disent non non non moi la politique
c'est ma vie c'est ça et je mourrai en
pensant réfléchissant comme un
responsable politique j'ai la prétention
où la faiblesse de penser que c'est un
métier contrairement à d'autres qui lie
sais pas maigrir non c'est un métier
c'est ça le fait bien ou mal hein c'est
une carrière ce sont des professionnels
pas des amateurs il faut de l'expérience
pour pour gouverner la france est
qu'aujourd'hui vous seriez meilleur
qu'avant avec le recul que vous avez
prime pas non mais alors oui alors je
fais un appel à tous les candidats à la
présidentielle s'il cherche anciens
premiers ministres ou ministres avec
expérience très gouverner je suis là bas
je dépense finition ce qui s'écrit
parfois sur les réseaux série avec tout
le monde comme un jeu bien évidemment je
peux vous faire la liste est elle
relativement longue mais le bien sûr que
je serai meilleur c'est vrai bien sûr
parce que quand on gouverne et pour la
première fois même si j'avais
l'expérience de cabinets ministériels
avec the spy rocard à ça fait très
longtemps
on commet des erreurs justement est-ce
que c'est pas la même chose pour un
président est ce que un président qui a
quand même été sur le terrain pendant
cinq ans est-ce que c'est pas compliqué
aussi d'en élire un autre après et de
repartir à zéro oui bien sûr parce que
je pense que la durée voilà la durée
pour changer un pays pour mener des
réformes pour les faire comprendre est
essentielle dans une démocratie moi je
moi je faisais du réel et interminable
je suis pour le septennat moi je trouve
que ça allait mieux mais on est ce que
je trouve que 50 c'est un peu court oui
je les ai souvent les présidents part
quand ils deviennent quand ils
commencent à comprendre le métier parce
que président c'est un métier qu'on
n'apprend pas mine de rien tous les mecs
qui arrivent président françois hollande
un nicolas sarkozy unis emmanuel macron
hills apprennent sur le terrain et donc
je me dis un moment et comment ça c'est
bon et au bout de cinq ans je trouve que
c'est un peu tôt je moi je trouvais que
le septennat c'était mieux oui double
septennat ça pouvait être loin la bce
pour certains mais c'est vrai que dit
ans aux états unis c maximum huit ans
donc mais aux états unis tout va plus
vite c'est vrai ce qui me paraît moi ce
qui me paraît très essentiel pour être
sérieux ce sujet c'est que le sait que
les grandes formations politiques au
fond se mettre d'accord secrètement pour
des réformes profondes mais pas sur
l'école pour les grands objectifs en
matière de 3,2 de changement climatique
court pour changer en profondeur le pays
pour traiter les questions aussi lourde
que l'immigration il faut du temps et de
la continuité donc pas que les majorités
qui se succèdent et comme seul objectif
de dire du mal ceux qui ont travaillé
avant parce qu'au fond quand vous
regardez les présidents écouter sarkozy
a à a bien géré la crise économique de
2008 françois hollande avec nous à
s'efface un pays qui pouvait se diviser
face aux attaques du terrorisme emmanuel
macron malgré toutes les critiques a à
gérer du mieux possible la crise
sanitaire donc si emmanuel macron vous
appeler demain pour être avec lui en
campagne et pour peut-être si vous fait
un ticket de jeu c'est pas de ministres
le premier ministre vous iriez ou pas je
sais pas moi je veux dire franchement
servir mon pays évidemment mais il me
l'a pas proposé
avec vous toute façon il était ministre
de mon gouvernement j'ai eu le nez creux
extraordinaire de lui proposer de venir
au gouvernement sont sidérantes il
allait m'aider génie politique
c'est lui françois hollande non on est
deux génies politiques
de prendre des mecs qui peuvent prendre
ma place
et ça arrive parfois la télé fait gaffe
moi je nomme je fais très attention à ça
des cas je dégage avant
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que c'est que cette histoire
parce que on va parler franchement moi
je fais emmanuel macron je me dis je les
ai quand même bien ah bah oui
franchement un moment oui mais il a
profité d'une situation qui était
l'effondrement de la gauche de
gouvernement le fait que françois
hollande donné des signes que moi je
voyais pas mais qu'il ne se
représenterait peut-être pas et donc il
est il a eu l'audace moi je pouvais pas
la voir parce qu'au fond ma vie dans un
parti politique le ps de nez des règles
au fond inter nommé mais que vous
intégrez font que vous n'avez pas cette
audace il l'a eu il a eu ses vous étiez
beaucoup de ces exposés mine de rien les
chances que ces annonces étaient cramés
ah ouais c'est ça écran mais pas partout
de la loi sur la le marché du travail le
49 3 l'insulté de la constitution mais
qui est devenu un espèce de deux
symboles par les divisions de la
majorité et lui il est apparu comme neuf
et ce qui se passe c'est que depuis son
élection le système continue à générer
du dégagisme de l'instabilité du
mécontentement
j'avais cru tout de suite à emmanuel
macron pas du tout vous est il y
arrivera jamais ah non moi au début je
pensais qu'il n'y arriverait pas je lui
ai dit je vous raconte une anecdote
un jour je rentre d'un prime time je ne
connaissais pas du tout emmanuel macron
mais je reçois un sms et c'était il est
encore ministre d'état bercy et il me
dit bonjour on a un ami en commun
qui s'appelle nicolas voilà il m'a donné
votre numéro je suis emmanuel macron
c'est déjà rencontrées à l'elysée cette
fameuse donc remise de médailles est-ce
qu est-ce qu on peut s'appeler parce que
j'ai l'intention de me présenter à la
présidentielle et là moi je me rappelle
je lui réponds mais c'est pour 2022
non non c'est pour 2017 il ça va être
dur
et on july bah oui on peut on peut
discuter et c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable parce que tout le monde se
disait à mon nom il sort de nulle part
il a vu la brèche me alors que tous les
îles à une puce donc plus la chance la
chance de la chance et c'est fillon qui
sut qu'à une affaire c'est la gauche qui
désigne benoît hamon plus tôt il a eu la
chance mais bon comme dit l'autre elle
sourit aux audacieux non moi j'ai vu ça
plutôt février-mars c'est un peu un peu
conscients de monde on était au début
oui d'une certaine manière à cause de sa
manière de partir de gouvernement mais
très honnêtement je considère qu'à ce
moment là le pays a plutôt une chance
dans ce mouvement de dégagements d'avoir
un président jeune réformiste
progressistes européens plutôt qu'entre
hommes on s'auto marine le pen donc donc
et l'idée d'avoir un deuxième tour en
plus entre françois fillon qui étaient
touchés par les affaires et l'extrême
droite représentée par marine le pen
m'inquiétais c'est pour ça que j'aime
les manettes l'état les voilà à ce
moment là mais qui fasse attention parce
que le même système qui a produit ça
peut produire du dégage il en gouverne
pas seul un pays il devra répondre à la
question un deuxième quinquennat pour
quoi faire bon il serait il ne sera plus
la nouveauté jab sûr qu'il va se
représenter
je crois que c'est la logique en tout
cas même si c'était une décision intime
mais c'est la logique peut-être pour les
raisons que vous évoquez tout à l'heure
c'est à dire qu'il faut la continuer
savait déjà pour qui vous allez voter je
n'en demande pas pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez déjà ou pas du tout non non
parce qu'au fond je j'ai deux idées la
première c'est celui ou celle qui sera
le plus c'est pas facile en capacité de
réconcilier les français avec eux mêmes
a eu la politique et la démocratie vaste
programme et 2 celui qui évite
évidemment le basculement du pays dans
le populisme emmanuel macron soit bien
placée pour représenter ça c'est
indéniable et je pense que le débat est
ouvert et précisément dans ma situation
je suis plus engagé au sens partisan je
regarde aussi et puis
ça m'intéresse d'être présent dans votre
émission parce que je sais que ce qui
nous regarde et nous écoutent et met
aussi les sentiments et j'ai envie dans
cette période bien sûr écouter les
français et de faire partager qu'on aime
ou n'aime pas ma propre expérience ce
que je vous trouve vraiment très franc
et son nombril boîte la droite vraiment
c'est justement c'est pour ça que je
vous posais cette question vous avez vu
que la candidate à gauche c'est anne
hidalgo vous avez bien roulé pour connu
c'est ici
alors
on peut être franc bon d'abord c'est
l'aèdes à l heure nous avons les mêmes
liens avaient d'origine oui c'est vrai l
andalousie moi je suis passé au
lendemain il faut faire attention mais
mai et ensuite je la trouve plutôt
courageuse d'essayer de représenter ce
courant politique de l'âme aux réformes
lancées autant de travaux mais
dans l'état où et paris parfois je
faisais quelque chose quand on a quitté
paris pendant trois ans et quand on
revient dans cette ville cette ville au
delà des 11 x files de circulation
norden notre île contraire c'est pas
vrai dit au delà des problèmes de
circulation réelle et le quelques petits
problèmes de propreté
la ville et il n'y est pour rien passé
paris sariska mais la tour eiffel ce
soir je le savais pas monnet
mais cette ville elle est tellement
magnifique mais je la trouve plutôt
courageuse d'essayer de nous représenter
ce courant politique mais mais je
reconnais que ça va être très très très
difficile mais attention on est au mois
de septembre exactement ces gens
oublient balladur il veut être président
et balladur est président au quart de l
aide car devait être réélu je peux vous
faire toute la ligne jospin est élu et
il est voilà voilà on va voir